Wehaveavoicemailnumber,thatnumberis219,toDavidP.Thelastcoupleofdays,I'vetakena
lotofhitsasaresultofmycoverageoftheDemocraticprimary.Alotofpeopledon'tlikethat.I
don'tseeamathematicalpathforburningtothenomination.
Therearepeoplewhodon'tlikethatwhenitcomesdowntoit.InNovember,I'mgoingtovotefor
bidinoverTrumpandI'veoutlinedthereasonswhyalotofpeople,angrywithme.
WetookseveralhundredunsubscribeonourYouTubechannelyesterdayasaresult.Andlisten,
that'sokay.
IcanonlydotheshowthewayI'mgonnadoit,I'mnotgonnadoanyofthisstuffwhereIgive
peoplefalsehopethatdoesn'tmakesenseorIpretendliketheonlyreasonBernielostisbecauseof
theDNCestablishment.LikeI'mnotgonnalietoyou,Okay,ifyouwantthatornotnecessarilythat
youwantpeopletolietoyou,butifyouwantpeopletotellyouthatyoucanfindshowsthatI'm
03/13/20 Page15of18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­12­commercialfree
surearedoingit.
Andhere'savoicemail.Igotsortofrelatedtothisbigpictureissueasinwhatiswrongatthe
ProgressiveMovementrightnowaftertherovingBernietookitonTuesday.AllI'mhearingfrom
Progressivesourceisabunchofexcusesandfear­mongering.They'renowtryingtoputimpress
upontheiraudiencesthatJoeBidencan'tpossiblybeTrump.Whatthehellisgoingon,dothey
wantTrumptowin?Thisisnothelpfulandtheykeeptalkingabouthowburningstillhadthe
chance.Lookattheanalytics.Heisnotfavoredinasinglestateleftrightnow,she'sdoinghorribly
amongblackpeople,he'sdoingwellwithHispanics,buthe'sdoinghorriblywithHispanicin
Florida.Barcan'twin,andweneedtoacceptthis.He'sonlygettingabout35%ofthevote,his
constituencyisnotshowingup.
Yeah,that's...That'salltrue,andI,Iunderstandhavingbeenthroughabunchoftheseelections
now.AndthinkingbacktothedisappointmentwhenGeorgeW.Bushwaseventuallyawardedthe
presidencyoverAlGorethat'sthefirstpresidentialelectionIfollowedreallyclosely.
Igetthefeeling,Iknowwhatpeopleareexperiencingbutmyargumentiswedon'tdoanybetterin
futureelections,ifwejustsay,Guys,youknowwhathappened,itwastheestablishmentanditwas
themediathatmadeitsothatBernielostandhestillhasachance.
Ifthat'syourview,thesamethingwillhappennexttime,okay,wehavetoincludeinouranalysis,
theelectorateisnotasprogressiveasTwitterandreaditmakesthinktheelectoratemaylike
MedicareforAllintheabstract,butwhenyousayexactlyhowitwillwork,it'snotaspopular.Igot
intoTwitterargumentsyesterdayaboutthat.Guys,thisisjustthereality,it'snotmyopinion.When
yougivemoredetailaboutBernie'sMedicareforAllplan,supportgoesdown,doesn'tmeanit'sa
badpolicydoesn'tmeanit'sthewrongpolicy,butit'snotjustthemedia,it'snotjusttheDNC.Joe
BidenrightnowisleadingBernieby15millionvotes.
TheideathatthisissimplybecausetheDNCtookitfromBernie.Ifitmakesyoufeelbetter,go
withit.Butwewillnotwinelectionswhenthatisthepredominantanalysis.AndIwannawin,I
wannawin,that'smyconcernandIalsowhenitcomesdowntoit,Idon'twantDonaldTrump
choosingRuthBaderGinsburg,asRuthBaderGinsburg.Sreplacement.Idon'twantthatI'drather
itbeby...
Igetthatwe'regonnahavesomeaudiencerolloverasaresultofthisbecausetherearepeoplewho
justdon'twannahearit.Hereatsomepeople.Wewillloseforgood.Somepeoplewillleavefora
whileandtheneventuallycomeback.Ican'tgaugemycommentaryorcalibratemycommentaryon
thatbasis,IjusthavetotellwhatIseeasthetruth.Ifyouseethedatadifferently.That'sagreat
debatetoengagein...KyleColinsky.AndIdidthatonTwitteryesterday,wewentbackandforth
aboutsomeoftheseMedicarenumbers.Butcallingmeacentristasapejorative,allofthatstuff
asidefrombeinguntrueandmebeingmoreprogressivethanI'veeverbeeninmyentirelifebased
onallofthecountlesstests,tofolkshavesentmeandthatI'vetaken.
We'renotgonnawinbysaying,"OhifIbelieveBerniehaslost.Iamacenters.chilwe.
We'rejustnotgonnawin.Andmaybethat'swhatsomepeoplewant.Maybesomepeoplewanna
03/13/20 Page16of18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­12­commercialfree
perpetuallybeinsortofthevictimontheoutsideupthe...Andthere'ssomethingtobesaidforthat
thatcanfeelgoodtoalotofpeople.There'salotofpsychologythat'sgoingonherethatexceeds
myabilitytomention,mentionhere,butIhopethatwecanallsortofcometogetherandagreeasto
whatitisthatisgoingonthiselection.
Wehaveagreatbonusforyoutoday.DonaldTrumpwantsbigshocker.Abailoutforthehotel
industry,theNBAhascanceled,orsuspended,theremainderoftheirseasonasmultipleplayers
nowhavethevirusandHarveyWeinsteinEinstein,it'sEricWeinstein,HarveyWeinsteinhasbeen
sentencedto24yearsinprison,andthatisabigcasewhichwewillbetalkingaboutonthebone,
it'sshowtoday,getaccesstothebonussodon'tmissit.RameshatjoinAmandotcomormakea
pledgeonPatreon,atPatreon.dotcom.DavidpacktheDavidPacmanshowatDavidPacman